another story from the post-millennial
sound of freedom is a smashing success
projected to earn over 40 million
dollars in opening week tremendous it
was an amazing film I vouch for it I
gave it a 10 out of 10. uh I I was on
the edge of my seat the whole time the
theater was crying it was a it was a
really really great film a great
Thriller Angel Studios is announcing
that uh I'm sorry estimates are are
predicting a massive 40 million dollars
the box office since opening week in a
press release had a theatrical
distribution for Angel Studios Brandon
Purdy said as with our July 4th numbers
today's numbers exceed our expectations
and we're going to continue this
momentum sound of Freedom has taken on a
life of its own winning rule that's huge
I Love The Way They promoted this movie
I mean one of the things that I saw in
lead up was like uh if buy a ticket for
someone else because we want to get what
was it several million people to the
theater to represent you know all the
children who were involved in in
trafficking and I thought that was
really cool it was sort of refreshing
and this is not by any means Associated
the Barbie movie but you know Barbie
movie has been largely about like very
stage press appearances and you know
it's kind of cool if that's your thing
but also this one had sort of more
meaning to it and I think people are
really hungry I feel like they are they
are part of the change in the world I
actually watched it last night and it
was so wonderful but I went home and I
felt like I'd been radicalized I was
like oh my gosh so I started looking up
stuff and you know I love my deleted web
pages so actually I published a story
today Biden's doj so they have a child
sex trafficking website and not in that
sense like it's their informational page
where they actually talk about their
subject areas that they focus on and in
May of 2023 they revised which keep in
mind weird timing right that's like
three years into the year two years into
the administration but they actually
revised the child sex trafficking
portion of the doj website and they I
kid you not removed the subheadings and
multi-paragraph explanations of
international sex trafficking of minors
domestic sex trafficking of minors and
child victims of prostitution and they
reworded what exactly they defined child
sex trafficking as taking out a whole
blurb where they talk about how it
involves like the transportation between
two countries so that made my
conspiratorial mind go like what the
heck the brain just lights up if you and
if you read the blurbs that they deleted
it's literally talking about how open
borders make child sex trafficking a
heck of a lot easier and when I saw that
I was like that's like like imagine just
imagine you're like some Biden staff or
like your job is like you run the doj's
website what would take over for you to
delete that from the informational web
page about child like it's it's just
bizarre why they do it I because they're
trafficking children
maybe I said maybe I'm not saying that
but maybe I would like an explanation
what a good tactic to learn rather than
read the old one and read the new one
you read what was removed it's like an
Elimination Diet that's what I do I do
my text comparisons and I see what they
take out and you connect they took they
deleted their it was called the China
challenge website where they described
the Chinese Communist party as like an
existential threat to the United States
on the first day of the Biden
Administration they also took down a web
page profiling all of the atrocities and
basically genocide going on against the
uyghurs and xinjiang and they literally
took China off
um the list of like adversarial threats
uh taking taking on and taking over the
United States so you can tell a lot and
all this was done the first day of of
the Biden Administration so like someone
is very very radical who's running their
their website so I just can't believe
they took it and this film was made five
years ago and for some reason they
wouldn't put it out and it was very very
difficult for them to finally do it and
it makes 40 million bucks in its opening
week which is massive for for any indie
film and it's really massive accounting
that it made 10 million on the first day
14.5 14.5 on the first day so that's 25
million in the six following days which
is huge for an indie film to go from
to increase its I guess to to make a
hundred and fifty percent of its opening
day over the net over the course of the
week I would have thought that that
indicates that I got a lot of good
publicity I think in Word of Mouth yeah
I think a lot of people are are
referring other people to the movie
which hopefully will mean it uh sustains
the profit margins for a long time
Grassroots movie what this means is that
anti-establishment anti-woke
libertarian-minded individuals
conservatives affected liberals whatever
this group is actually engaging in the
culture War I know one guy that said he
bought a ticket didn't didn't want to go
because he didn't know if he could
handle it but he still wanted to support
the movie yeah like that's I don't hear
that a lot about a lot of movies but I'm
excited for Barbie I think I like about
this no no I don't mean to say Barbie
but I did think this idea that they were
saying like the most important thing to
us is that people sit in the theater and
see the movie so if you can buy a ticket
for someone else like if you can help
people get this message out there that's
what we care about and I think that is
the part of the cultural war that people
are really wanting to be part of it's
not the crocheted Barbie at all but we
can do a great I mean all the success in
the world to Barbie but I think it is
interesting that this movie that you're
right I mean it would be hard to watch
it would be hard to see people are still
flocking to see if they want they want
to know what's going on hopefully it's
Barbie had that scene they're they're
getting slammed because it shows the
lines coming out of China the nine Dash
lines there's only eight in the movie
but it represents China's claim over the
South China Sea so and that's in Barbie
and so the movie's getting banned and a
bunch of Southeast Asians it's like it's
this whole abstract world map and it's
like this dashed s line in in real life
it's basically like a you uh but Barbie
is it makes me wonder was that
intentional Barbie hasn't said or the
makers of Barbie I should say haven't
said if this was like they want to make
money in China right or now I can't see
Barbie I almost wonder if they're
they had no idea what they were doing I
think they want to make money in China I
think that's ultimate but I do like the
idea that someone drew the map and was
like I know I looked up a map and there
were some dashes that could play the
dumb blonde card yeah it's this this is
their out we had no idea what we were
doing
that's actually what they said they said
it's just a fake map that Barbie Drew up
like it's about why did Barbie know
about the line exactly like why yeah if
it's such a silly cartoonish map why are
those lines there and I don't know
Vietnam in front but uh see exactly
we have it you can you can see right
here
um I don't know if I via the Philippines
was reviewing this and they were saying
maybe some of their lawmakers were
suggesting perhaps this scene could be
edited out so this map doesn't appear
but I don't know how that went it may
just be if you look over here on the
other parts of the map there are other
dotted lines it may may have been to
represent just like traveling not
actually anything and because there's
lines coming out of Asia like this is
not even the shape of Asia like what is
this no it's a complete abstract map
because it's silly but
on the other hand I do like the idea
that someone just was like map of the
world didn't think about it at all and
now they've like entered this movie to
huge geopolitical yes debate yeah the
occult people in the in the film and
movie industry a lot of times are very
manipulative with thing with imagery so
they might have been like this is a
travel path but they happen to make the
travel path the cutout that they want to
be given to the Chinese
um Authority that's possible and we'll
probably never know I mean no one's No
One's Gonna Come Out and explain it you
have two choices this weekend America
you can support China by watching Barbie
where you can support America
and saving kids but watching sound of
Freedom which Which Way Oppenheimer as a
third choice is not on the table are
people saying is it good I don't know no
I never see any movies don't look at me
I gotta go see sound of freedom I think
I might go tomorrow yeah bro you're
gonna be crying the whole time oh no
yeah oh geez dude the opening scene is
so well done in that movie what I was
saying earlier is like if everyone here
is seen up right no no you haven't seen
up no no no wow is it like good well the
first yeah
the first sequence is amazing it's
really solid the first 15 minutes will
leave you balling your eyes out really
in up and then the rest of the movie is
kind of like okay I don't even care like
I liked that I I thought with children
though and I was like Sal I don't have
to worry about anything in here first
the first 15 minutes or whatever of up
is is one of the best short films ever
and then afterwards it's silly nonsense
I don't care about was it a short movie
that they turned into a feature like no
it's the Expo it's like basically the
intro to the film to explain
why the movie's happening I mean look
I'm gonna spoil up for you because it's
been available let me tell you what I
know of it by not having seen it it's a
guy whose house they're gonna repossess
and he's like no I'd rather fly away
it's just with no words the story of how
he got his house and and what led him to
it's him as a little kid meeting a
little girl then it's a montage with
music of them growing up they long to
travel the world they have a jar they're
saving up money but then things keep
happening as a leak in the roof the car
breaks down so they keep breaking open
the savings and spending the savings on
things other than their dream trip and
then one day his wife Brock wants to buy
it his wife dies and so he's just old
curmudgeon who lives in this house and
now his city has sprung up around him
and so that's like the first 10 minutes
or whatever in sound of Freedom the
first 10 minutes
um I won't spoil completely
but the intro sequence not there okay so
there's there's like the opening credits
and then there's the opening scene
the opening credits has real video of
children being snatched by traffickers
it's terrifying like
it's horrifying to see how like it'll
it's it's surveillance footage of two
little kids like playing basketballs at
their house and a car pulls up and they
just grab the kid and throw them in the
other kids starts freaking out just like
that but the opening sequence basically
without spoiling anything just lays out
the general concept of what's happening
and it's it was like
it was it was it was a weird kind of
fear I've seen you watch a horror movie
and you're like oh man there's gonna be
a jump scare or something you're like
scared you're not really scared yo I was
kind of scared watching I'm like in in
the beginning with everything that's
going on I'm feeling like this fear and
this dread this Doom because I know
exactly you you watch you know exactly
what's about to happen and then you
watch it happen and then your fear anger
and Dread becomes like anger and sadness
it's a good movie man because sadness is
better than fear so yeah it's worth
seeing but it's like a kind of fear when
you know where it's going and you're
waiting for it to happen and like oh man
do you feel I recommend it do you feel
better equipped to deal with it on the
global stage having seen that movie oh I
don't know I think it I think that movie
is going to put it in people's minds
though and I think a whole lot of people
in Hollywood and DC are freaking out
right now and how successful this is so
that's your third reason to go see it
the first is because it's a good movie
the second is because we want to build
up alternate Studios who can compete
with Hollywood and the third reason is
to piss off the creepos who are in
Hollywood in DC who are fuming that
people are starting to call out their
creepy grooming trafficking Behavior
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time